[Musik]
die geschichte der feuerwehr reicht bis
in die römerzeit zurück damals mussten
sich vornehmlich sklaven der brennenden
gefahr aussetzen im mittelalter sorgten
die zündstoff für die brandbekämpfung
aber erst mit einem mann wurde in
deutschland die feuerwehr nachhaltig
strukturiert konrad dittrich magirus er
gilt bis heute als der pionier in der
feuerwehrtechnik hier in seiner
heimatstadt ulm entwickelte er zunächst
feuerspritzen und leiter mit der
sogenannten ulmer leiter gelang ihm 1873
der ganz große wurf und durchbruch sie
war auch ein highlight auf der
weltausstellung in wien exemplare
existieren heute zwar nicht mehr aber
zahllose andere errungenschaften von
magirus die heute von experten wie karl
hermann bis ins detail dokumentiert
werden hermann hat sich lange mit dem
facettenreichen leben von konrad magirus
auseinandergesetzt
also contra wittlich magirus war ein
richtiger mache er hat also erkannt dass
die brandbekämpfung den historischen
stätten von wichtigkeit ist und dass es
verbessert werden muss und er hat sich
durchgesetzt und er hat dann auch
erkannt dass die geräte verbessert
werden müssen und hat die ersten geräte
bauen lassen konrad dittrich magirus
machte es sich aber nicht nur zur
aufgabe neue geräte zur feuerbekämpfung
zu bauen er strukturierte auch die
männer an der feuerfront neu er brauchte
nicht nur mutig sondern auch sportliche
männer und die fand er in seiner ulmer
turnerschaft nur sie waren anfangs in
der lage mit schwerem gerät in riesige
höhen zu klettern und gleichzeitig noch
brände zu löschen
als erster kommandant der ulmer
feuerwehr war er stets am puls der zeit
und kannte die bedürfnisse und
anforderungen im brandeinsatz in der
folge produzierte magirus transportable
leitern die zunächst von pferden und
später auch von dampfmaschinen gezogen
wurden
1893 schließlich kam die erste drehbare
leiter zum einsatz ein quantensprung
erlebte die feuerwehr mit der
motorisierung anfang der zwanzigerjahre
magirus hat etwas wichtiges getan er hat
zunächst auch
eine anleitung geschrieben das
feuerlöschwesen in allen seinen teilen
und hat das heft dieses buch verbreitet
man konnte nachlesen wie man feuerwehr
organisieren soll und organisieren muss
und magirus hat wert gelegt dass die
leute freiwillig dienst leisten und sich
freiwillig dazu verpflichten für eine
stadt für eine gemeinde für diese
aufgabe feuerwehr zur verfügung zu
stehen die leute waren hoch motiviert
sie kamen meistens in süddeutschland aus
der turnerschaft wenn man beim feuer ran
musste über die leitern und es waren
akrobatische taten die haben den
schlauch über die schulter genommen und
sind über die leitern hochland an das
feuer und das waren die turner und das
war magirus sein ziel dass die thuner
sich in der feuerwehr einbringen es
waren immer freiwillige wir haben bis
heute den begriff freiwillige feuerwehr
die gerne ehrenamtlich freiwillig diesen
dienst gemacht haben und hoch motiviert
waren für die gesellschaft für die stadt
für das dorf was gutes zu tun und man
konnte die leute hoch motivieren am
brandschutz mitzuwirken weil sie gesehen
haben dass bei feuer alles zunichte wird
und man muss dem entgegenwirken und wenn
jemand was freiwillig macht ist es ja
von vor von hoher wichtigkeit und auch
nebenbei kostengünstig kein wunder also
dass die feuerwehr des heute höchstes
ansehen in der bevölkerung genießt mit
ihr verbindet man mutige charakterstarke
und vertrauensvolle männer die sich
freiwillig für das gemeinwohl einsetzen
[Musik]
magirus ist seinen ulmer wurzeln stets
treu geblieben
hier im donautal werden die modernsten
feuerwehrfahrzeuge zu 100 prozent von
hand gebaut einer der bekanntesten ist
die drehleiter
basiselemente sind hierbei hochfeste
stahlprofile die zunächst auf maß
gesenkt werden viele der mitarbeiter
sind selbst feuerwehrangehörige und
gehen mit entsprechendem herzblut ans
werk
nach dem zuschnitt kommen die stäbe in
eine überdimensionale waschmaschine und
werden hier von fett staub und spänen
gereinigt
jetzt kommen die schweizer ans werk hier
muss im wahrsten sinne des wortes jede
naht sitzen ein fehler könnte fatale
folgen im einsatz haben doch die männer
sind vollprofis jeder von ihnen setzt
naht und schweiß punkt auf den
millimeter genau
hans ulrich walter ist selbst
feuerwehrmann und kennt daher die
bedeutung der schweiß arbeiten
sind bis zu 100 einzelteile pro leiter
die hier von hand zusammen geschweißt
worden
die schweißarbeiten erfolgen in mehreren
etappen durch die extrem hohen
temperaturunterschiede und der daraus
resultierenden verformung der werkstücke
muss das schweißen besonders behutsam
erfolgen
damit die leiter in der praxis auch
hohen extremen temperaturen gewappnet
ist wird er in der nächsten abteilung
mit einer speziellen flamm technik die
notwendige eigene spannung und form
gegeben
das auge ist sehr sehr wichtig bei
diesen
man erlernt dass nach einer gewissen
zeit
zwar können sich die arbeiter auch
messgeräten bedienen letztendlich aber
verlassen sie sich auf ihre langjährige
erfahrung und ihren geschulten blick
auch hier wird absolute perfektion
abverlangt die leiter darf bei eisigen
temperaturen aber auch in der wüste ihre
spannkraft verlieren mit dem brenner
werden falsche krümmungen oder
unebenheiten ausgebügelt im gegensatz zu
handelsüblichen leiten lassen unsere
leitung beim flammen richten vorgespannt
das heißt sie erhalten eine gummierung
eine biegung nach oben damit sie im
belasteten zustand maximal gerade worden
nicht nur die leiter auch der großteil
weiterer bauelemente wie zum beispiel
die montage des unter wagens werden fast
zu 100 prozent von hand produziert
eine maschine wäre hierzu nicht in der
lage hier
entsteht der unterbau einer drehleiter
besteht aus zwei längs profilen an denen
verschiedene hydraulische elemente
bereits hier vormontiert werden dort
sind alle ventile für die note
betätigung befestigt und wurde nun vor
ort
hier würden auch schon vorbereitungen
für den aufbau des tre getriebes auf dem
hilfsrahmen getroffen und auch die
zylinder so die fehler abstützung
bereits angebracht
die aufschläger werden von
unterschiedlichen herstellern geliefert
müssen jedoch vor der montage erst
konfiguriert werden damit die eigenen
bauteile auch normgerecht verbaut werden
können
nebenan werden die boden seiten und
deckt bleche für die geräte aufbauten
der drehleiter auf maß gefertigt ein
drehleiter aufbau besteht aus über 30
verschiedenen blechteilen auch hier muss
millimeter und passgenau gearbeitet
werden damit die bleche auch bündig
angepasst werden können
jede feuerwehr hat bei der ausstattung
individuelle wünsche die dann von den
ingenieuren und schließlich von den
technikern umgesetzt werden
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit nimmt der leiter
satz form und gestalt an von einer
handelsüblichen stehleiter ist dieses
hightech gerät weit sehr weit entfernt
hier nun die leiter teile zusammen
geschoben nachdem sie vom lackieren und
pulverbeschichten zurück sind je nach
modell erreichen die leitern eine höhe
von 27 bis 60 metern damit sie auch in
dieser höhe sicher ausfahrbar und
bedienbar sind ist nicht nur ein
spezieller edelstahl notwendig sondern
auch eine ausgeklügelte technologie und
steuerung die heutzutage natürlich von
computern unterstützt wird so war die
einführung der single extension eine
völlig neue auszugs technik der
drehleiter gewiss ein meilenstein
hierdurch kann die drehleiter noch
individueller und flexibler zum einsatz
gebracht werden ein wichtiger
bestandteil der drehleiter ist auch die
kommunikationseinheit
diese stationen worden die ganzen
elektrischen verbindungen im leitsatz in
den leider satz eingezogen das heißt die
verbindungen vom rettungskorb hinunter
bis zu den rechnern im tre getriebe
elektrische verbindungen dient der
kommunikation und auch der
stromversorgung in moskau damit das
enorme gewicht einer bis zu 60 meter
hohen leiter auch in extremsituationen
reibungslos funktioniert bedarf es
natürlich auch einer entsprechenden
hydraulik im unterbau um enorme kräfte
ziehen beim einsatz am material jedes
hydraulik element wird vor dem einbau
getestet und auf mögliche
undichtigkeiten überprüft um
verunreinigungen zu vermeiden bedient
man sich einer speziellen
druckluftpistole im anschluss werden die
filigranen hydraulikleitungen verbaut
mit jeder technischen innovation steigt
auch die anforderungen an die arbeit
[Musik]
hier sind das träge triebe also das
untergestell für die leitung für den
leiter sachs wird hier mit den drei
komponenten bestückt und gleichzeitig
geprüft der unterbau muss mehrere
funktionen gleichzeitig erfüllen er muss
zum einen möglichst geringes
eigengewicht mit sich bringen um auch
ökologische wie ökonomische vorgaben zu
erfüllen aber auch gleichzeitig halt
balance und mobilität für eine
tonnenschwere leiter garantieren
insbesondere das gesamtgewicht der
drehleiter bei stetig steigender leiter
höhe ist immer wieder eine
herausforderung für die ingenieure
hier sehen wir nun ein vollständiges tre
getriebe
die drei komponenten wie die aus
fahrbinde auf rechts linda die zylinder
von denen einige bewegung und auch schon
derbe dienst land ist bereits eingebaut
auf diesem aufrecht rahmen und nachher
die drehleiter befestigt und die
drehleiter sogar mit angehoben
beziehungsweise geneigt
parallel dazu wird das aufbau gerippe
auf den fahrwerk rahmen montiert auch
hier gilt es jedes bauteil so leicht und
effizient wie möglich zu konstruieren
jedes kilo gewicht bedeutet weniger
reserve für ausrüstung für den einsatz
aber gleichzeitig auch mehr
treibstoffverbrauch
die aufbauten links und rechts am
fahrzeug sind für zusätzlichen stauraum
von lösch und bergungsgerät gedacht eine
folge der großen bandbreite in der eine
drehleiter eingesetzt werden kann
auch ein drehleiterfahrzeug
transportiert bei weitem nicht nur die
leiter sondern zahlreiche weitere
technische hilfsmittel zur
brandbekämpfung und rettung jeder
zentimeter wird hier sinnvoll verplant
und genützt hier würden circa 200
drehleiter fahrzeuge jedes jahr
gefertigt die von ulm aus in die ganze
welt vertrieben werden so auch die
tanklöschfahrzeuge die in einer weiteren
halle montiert werden auch hier werden
mehrere fahrzeugtypen mit
unterschiedlicher größe und ausstattung
hergestellt wie bei den drehleitern
werden fahrerkabine sowie fahrwerk und
aufleger direkt von dem gewünschten
herstellern geliefert alfred
bittlingmaier betreut die produktion
seit jahrzehnten und kennt praktisch
jede schraube an den löschfahrzeugen
wir haben hier nun dieses lkw
fahrgestell wie es vom hersteller uns
angeliefert wurde das passt aber für den
feuerwehrtechnischen aufbau nicht in
allen punkten zum beispiel im rahmen
überhang müssen wir noch einige
abänderungen durchführen um für einen
optimalen einbau der feuerwehr pumpe zu
sorgen
auch der über 300 meter langen
fertigungsstraße werden bis zu 70
fahrzeuge gleichzeitig in
unterschiedlichen stationen aufgebaut
eine der ersten bauphase ist hierbei der
zuschnitt der metallplatten für boden
dach und seitenflächen
hier werden bereits per
computersteuerung alle einlässe und
öffnungen für spätere bauelemente
freigelegt
hier wird nun die öffnung für den schaum
tank hergestellt und die öffnung für den
wassertank eine spezial kreissäge sorgt
für den perfekten schnitt 1 millimeter
am ziel vorbei und die platte ist
wertlos entsprechend behutsam gehen die
techniker bei ihrer arbeit vor im
gegensatz zur klassischen automobil
produktion kommt hier nichts von der
stange sondern jedes fahrzeug ist
praktisch ein unikat entsprechend
unterschiedlich gestalten sich auch die
anforderungen für den zuschnitt ist
der erfolg kommt die platte zum
ausgangspunkt der fertigungsstraße hier
befindet sich der punkt null für jedes
löschfahrzeug nach einer begradigung der
kanten kann mit dem aufbau der einzelnen
leichtmetall elemente begonnen werden
aus unzähligen einzelteilen entsteht
schritt für schritt ein hoch modernes
löschfahrzeug
für den zusammenbau hat man sogar eine
eigene technik entwickelt
wir kommen nun zum aluminium bereich
hier werden in einem baukastensystem die
feuerwehr aufbauten hergestellt hierzu
hat unsere firma ein spezielles
baukasten profil entwickelt aus
unterschiedlichen profilen und mit
derartigen schraubt noten verbinden
können nun diese profile und flexibel
und variabel verschraubt werden
der anblick könnte einen laien schnell
zur verzweiflung bringt es gleicht einem
puzzle spiel
jahrelange routine gibt den technikern
jedoch die sicherheit für den richtigen
blick und das richtige teil
nach und nach entsteht der sogenannte
koffer des fahrzeugs er ist zum einen
hülle aber auch stauraum für alle
notwendigen werkzeuge und utensilien
beim einsatz
in unterschiedlichen etappen verbauen
die mechaniker die streben und verkleben
schließlich die seitenteile an der
konstruktion auch hier setzt man auf
leichte aber dennoch strapazierfähige
materialien letztlich ist auch das
löschfahrzeug bei der fahrt und beim
einsatzort enormen kräften ausgesetzt ob
bei hochwasser im schlamm oder holprigen
straßen im stadtgebiet
manche feuerwehrautos sind über 20 jahre
im einsatz entsprechend hochwertig muss
nicht nur das material sondern auch die
verarbeitung sein
dieses know how haben sich ingenieure
wie techniker über jahrzehnte erarbeitet
man kann auf eine über 150-jährige
geschichte und erfahrung im fahrzeug und
maschinenbau zurückgreifen
hier in ulm dessen münster schon bald
zum firmenlogo avancierte hat man mit
kleinen und pferde betriebenen lösch und
leiter fahrzeugen angefangen in der
folge machte sich das unternehmen auch
in der fertigung von bau- und
zugmaschinen sowie auch bussen einen
namen vom motor über fahrwerk und
aufbauten wurde alles aus einer hand
produziert
in den 20er jahren war magirus eines der
bedeutendsten unternehmen in deutschland
und zählte über 2.000 mitarbeiter
danach wechselten oft die besitzer und
beteiligungen was jedoch blieb war der
name magie muss
[Musik]
heute konzentriert man sich
ausschließlich auf den aufbau von lösch
und drehleiter fahrzeugen wenngleich die
pumpen hierzu noch selbst konstruiert
und gebaut werden kein wunder ist das
high tech gerät auch herzstück jedes
löschfahrzeuges
im innern der pumpe sind zwei solche
pumpen laufräder vorhanden die erste
stufe nimmt das wasser auf aus der
wasserentnahmestelle und übergibt sie an
die zweite stufe die dann den
gewünschten ausgangs druck erzeugen sind
alle notwendigen teile in und an der
pumpe montiert wird sie an den großen
wassertank verbaut je nach größe des
fahrzeuges um fasst der tank ein volumen
von bis zu 10.000 liter wasser
gerade in entlegenen regionen in denen
man nicht auf hydranten oder direkte
wassereinspeisung zurückgreifen kann ist
der tank von großer bedeutung
neben wasser kann das fahrzeug zudem
auch noch mit schaum pulver und co2 als
brandbekämpfung ausgestattet werden
jetzt gilt es den tank millimetergenau
auf die karosserie aufzusetzen ein
spannender moment bei dem gleich mehrere
mitarbeiter im einsatz sind
in diesem arbeitsplatz wurde die
hochzeit durchgeführt das heißt die
vereinigung von dem fahrgestell mit dem
eigentlichen herzstück des feuerwehr
aufbau ist nämlich dass kreiselpumpe und
den wassertank der wassertank hat 3000
liter inhalt und die pumpen pumpen
leistung von 2000 litern pro minute
in einer anderen fertigungsstraße baut
man inzwischen die rollos für die
stauräume 1 auch hier bedient man sich
natürlich eine leichtbauweise
wichtig ist dass die rollläden leicht
und einfach zu bedienen sind denn auch
hier geht es im einsatz um sekunden
ein weiteres bauelement ist das
blaulicht klar soll das blaulicht in
erster linie funktional und weit
sichtbar sein aber auch das thema design
spielt beim bau eine immer größere rolle
auch die blaulicht dass sie natürlich
ein wichtiges bestandteil aller
feuerwehrfahrzeuge früher waren die
blaulichter frei stehen der aufbau
montiert heute wünschen die meisten
kunden integriert in die
kunststoffverkleidung damit das fahrzeug
einen harmonischen abschluss nach hinten
bekommt neben dem akustischen signal gab
es auch ein optisches signal
als die ersten fertig gezogenen
feuerwehreinheiten mit spritzen und
leitern ausgerückt sind waren fackeln
das signal nur die feuerwehr hatte
fackeln an ihren werken an ihren fertig
gezogenen welchen diese fackeln hat man
sehr weit gesehen als dann die
automobile kamen war strom dabei dann
hat man rotlicht wurden rotes blinklicht
auf die automobile gebaut und erst
1938 36 hat man festgestellt dass man
dieses rotlicht sehr weit sieht aber in
vorbereitungen eines krieges wollte man
eigentlich dass man nicht weit sieht und
kobaltblau war dann die farbe die man
nicht weit gesehen hat feindliche
flieger konnten dieses kobaltblau eben
nicht so sehen darum war ab 38
vorgeschrieben rotlicht scheiben
auszutauschen gegen blaue scheiben und
daher kommt es dass des can lichtblau
ist
für die wiedererkennung der
feuerwehrautos ist natürlich auch die
lackierung entscheidend wenngleich es
hier von bundesland zu bundesland kleine
abweichungen in der farbgebung sowie in
der gestaltung und anordnung gibt
[Musik]
in der fertigungsstraße kommt es zur
zweiten hochzeit
hier wird der karosserie koffer über die
tank und pumpen einheit geführt jetzt
zeigt sich ob die monteure exakt und
passgenau gearbeitet haben jedes
fahrzeug ist anders insofern müssen sich
die techniker immer wieder auf neue maße
einstellen ein fehler würde die
produktion empfindlich stören daher ist
die erleichterung jedes mal groß wenn
alle schraubverbindungen deckungsgleich
sind
zurück in den produktionshallen für die
drehleiter auch hier bahnt sich ein
großer moment an das dreh getriebe der
drehleiter wird auf das fahrzeug gehoben
und mit dem unterbau verbunden in den
20er jahren wurde das erste motorisierte
drehleiterfahrzeug von magirus gebaut
heute über 80 jahre später hat sich am
grundaufbau und dem prinzip der technik
kaum etwas verändert
entsprechend lebt der geist und die
vision von konrad dittrich magirus in
jedem der hochmodernen fahrzeuge auch
weiter
deshalb ist es für alle beteiligten
immer wieder ein bewegender moment wenn
die so genannte hochzeit bei der
drehleiter fertigung fast schon
zelebriert wird
man verspürt in den gesichtern des teams
auch einen gewissen stolz
schließlich hat mit der berühmten ulmer
leiter der aufstieg im wahrsten sinne
des wortes begonnen
eine weitere unersetzliche komponente
ist der rettungskorb mit ihm ist man in
der lage opfer auch liegend aus
gefahrensituationen zu retten zudem sind
im korb auch wichtige kommunikations
einheiten eingebaut die einen perfekten
dialog zwischen den einzelnen
einsatztruppen sowie dem kommando
ermöglichen
wir haben für unsere drehleiter und zwei
verschiedene karten einmal mit 300 kilo
nutzlast und einmal mit 400 kilo
nutzlast da jedes fahrzeug individuell
auf die bedürfnisse der jeweiligen
feuerwehr hergestellt wird erfolgen
immer wieder zwischen abnahmen zudem
möchten die männer natürlich möglichst
frühzeitig einen blick auf ihr neues
gefährt werfen so können die neuen
besitzer auch miterleben wenn in die
drehleiter zum ersten mal leben
eingehaucht wird und sich hightech fast
schon filigran wie eine schlange durch
die test alle schlängelt
drehleitern sind heute hoch komplexe und
sensible konstrukte in denen ein
intelligentes innenleben mit einer
robusten außenhaut in einklang gebracht
wird hier am drehleiter prüfstand
erwacht die drehleiter das erste mal zum
leben
sie wurden alle elektrischen
mechanischen und hydraulischen
funktionen überprüft
software aufgespielt
und eine komplette funktionsprüfung
einer jeden
in der fertigungsstraße der
löschfahrzeuge sind die elektriker
inzwischen dabei kabelstränge und
kabelbäume quer durch das fahrzeug zu
verlegen eine arbeit die nicht nur
fachkenntnis sondern auch
geschicklichkeit und ein gutes auge
abverlangt mit jeder neuen baureihe
wächst auch die technologie und damit
die anzahl an kabeln und verbindungen ja
um die hohen komfort und
sicherheitsvorschriften zu erfüllen ich
heute die elektronik ein unverzichtbares
bauteil bei allen feuerwehrfahrzeugen
und so haben wir heute in seiner
modernen feuerwehrfahrzeug über 3000
meter strom verkabelungen eingebaut die
strom verkabelungen versorgen
sicherheitseinrichtungen wie pumpen
schaltungen wie pumpen druck regel
anlagen sorgen auch dafür dass
automatisch die innenbeleuchtung in der
geräteräume einen ausgehen oder dass der
fahrer erkennt welche rouladen eventuell
noch geöffnet ist von kindesbeinen an
erkennt man die feuerwehr an drei
markanten zeichen und symbolen die rote
farbe das blaulicht auf dem dach und
natürlich das berühmte martinshorn was
kaum jemand weiß hinter letzterem steckt
sogar ein tieferer sinn und eine kleine
musikalische historie ja wie bei der
jagd so gibt's auch bei der feuerwehr
signale früher horn und trompeten
signale von feuerwehrfahrzeugen heute
sind solche
endlosen trompeten man kann sie auch als
verfahren bezeichnen auf dem dach
montiert und über einen druck
luftkompressor wird dann die luft
erzeugt die früher der trompeter gemacht
hat so das berühmte tatütata hat man
heute noch auf jeder modernen
feuerwehrfahrzeug alarmsignal wurde
früher mit der trompete geblasen
es hatte eine melodie und einen text der
text heißt feuerwehr gleich bei es
brennt es brennt es brennt und dieses es
brennt es brennt es brennt wurde dann
übernommen als
akustisches signal für das einsatzland
bei der feuerwehr ta ta ta ta es brennt
es brennt es brennt
das horn ist überall gleich ansonsten
aber gibt es große unterschiede
ja viele meinen feuerwehrautos sind alle
rot und sind alle gleich das ist
natürlich nicht der fall jedes fahrzeug
wurde individuell hergestellt zum
beispiel bei diesem fahrzeug mit einem
ab klappbaren hinterachs kotflügel
so dass man bequem und ökonomisch hier
die geräte entnehmen kann und am heck
des fahrzeuges hat dieser kunde auch
einen neuartigen lichtmast anbauen
lassen der bis sieben meter lichtpunkte
ausgefahren werden kann
schon der fertigungsstraße rollen die
brandbekämpfer schließlich in die
abnahme habe hier werden noch kleine
korrekturen beziehungsweise fittings
vorgenommen um das fahrzeug endgültig
für den export oder die abholung
vorzubereiten
in über 100 ländern sind die fahrzeuge
im einsatz von den wüsten am golf über
weite flächen in russland bis hin zu
engen häuserschluchten in hongkong
entsprechend gestaltet sich nicht nur
fahrwerk bereifung und aufbau sondern
auch die bestückung der fahrzeuge
hier hat jede feuerwehr und jedes land
unterschiedliche präferenzen für die
ausstattung mit
der einsatz breite wächst auch die
ausstattungsliste von modell zu modell
[Musik]
in einem solchen modernen
feuerwehrfahrzeug sind heutzutage
zwischen vier bis fünfhundert
unterschiedliche ausrüstungsteile
enthalten beginnen vom einfachen
schlauchboot hin zu komplizierten
hydraulischen rettungsgeräten und das
gewicht dieser feuerwehr taktischen
beladung ist rund 1,5 tonnen
so hier haben wir ein universal fahrzeug
ein fahrzeug das sich für alle möglichen
einsätze eigene der feuerwehr mit neun
mann besatzung und eine unmenge an
ausrüstung und geräten 2000 liter
löschwasser zusätzlich zum beispiel
stromgenerator
wir haben hier
13.000 watt strom dabei wir haben
beleuchtungs geräte kabeltrommeln
warngerät blitzlampen dabei
wir haben
übertrug gebläse dabei um den rauch aus
dem gebäude heraus zu blasen wir haben
eine schau zu mischung und die ganze
klassische lösch beladung weiterhin auf
diesem fahrzeug
auf der linken seite dieses fahrzeuge
sind die hydraulischen rettungsgeräte
gelagert wie man benötigt um kers bei
verkehrsunfällen die fahrzeuge
aufzuschneiden
spreizer und schere
rettungszylinder pedal schneider und das
weitere zubehör durch herausklappen
kommt man an die hinteren geräte kann
dann das fahrzeug besteigen und ein
weiterer geräte aus dem fahrzeuginneren
entnehmen da für jeden zweck das
richtige feuerwehrfahrzeug hier zum
beispiel ein fahrzeug für den
geländeeinsatz waldbrand busch
brandeinsätze im ländlichen bereich ein
fahrzeug mit 3000 liter wassertank und
einer einzel bereifung auf der
vorderachse und auf der hinterachse die
gleiche bereifung die vorderachse gräbt
die spur und die hinterachse kann in
dieser vorbereiteten spur das fahrzeug
mit voller kraft zur einsatzstelle
schieben
die drehleitern werden nach ersten grund
und software tests nun auch auf dem
freigelände in unterschiedlichen
szenarien und belastungs bereichen
getestet
die herausforderung besteht darin sowohl
bei einem häuser brand in 60 metern höhe
ebenso sicher und effizient zu arbeiten
wie bei einer rettung aus einem see oder
fluss bett
[Musik]
ziel ist es die drehleiter so zu
konstruieren dass sie sich möglichst
schnell den gegebenheiten anpasst und
mit ihr rasch der rettungs- oder
löscherfolg erzielt werden kann
[Musik]
letztendlich kann sie nur von der physik
gestoppt werden wie schon die alten
römer oder des fotos ulmer münster
verwendet wird hier mit einem not die
ausladung von der fahrzeug außenkante
bis zur vorderkante des rettungskorb es
ermittelt wir sind nun in dieser
position an einer vier personen grenze
und warum hier nun eine prüf last von
440 kilo aufbringen was der normalen
abschalt grenze an dieser position
entspricht
die leiter muss nicht nur ihr eigenes
gewicht sondern natürlich auch dass der
feuerwehrleute und deren gerät tragen
und in der balance halten
hinzu kommen rettung und bergung von
opfern alle szenarien schließen hier ein
und werden vom computer berechnet
diesem gerät wird die überlasst im
rettungskorb simuliert wir werden nun
hier eine last von 440 kilogramm
aufbringen
hier haben wir nun das signal das signal
bedeutet erreichen der belastungsgrenze
die leiter wird automatisch gestoppt um
die einsatzkräfte zu sichern die
schwerkraft ist ein gegner mit dem sich
die drehleiter auseinandersetzen muss
hinzu kommen aber auch unterschiedliche
bodenbeschaffenheiten sowie neigungen
und steigungen am einsatzort wichtig ist
dass der leiter satz und der
rettungskorb stets waagrecht bleiben
mittels zweier hydraulikzylinder können
schieflagen bis zu zehn grad oder 18
prozent ausgeglichen werden das träge
triebel bleibt somit immer in der
waagrechten egal wie schräg das fahrzeug
steht dank der technik hat sich auch das
einsatzgebiet der drehleiter enorm
erweitert
ein meilenstein ist ihr gewiss die
neuartige gelenk technologie wodurch man
auch überhänge und vorsprünge überwinden
kann so gewinnt die drehleiter im
löschzug immer mehr an bedeutung
können natürlich nicht nur in die höhe
fahren
sie können auch standardmäßig bis zu 17
grad
unterflur bereich abdecken und personen
aus schächten oder baugruben zu retten
hat man dazu noch eine gelenkarm leite
wie hier dann kann eine maximale tiefe
von 5,7 metern unter der fahrzeug
aufstellfläche erreicht worden ein grund
warum die leiter auch immer häufiger bei
unfällen zum einsatz kommt um diese auch
schnell und sicher zu erreichen
benötigen die fahrzeuge auch reichlich
kraft unter der haube
der einsatz am ort muss genau so sicher
sein wie die fahrt auch diese szenarien
werden auf einer eigens hierfür gebauten
teststrecke mit steilkurve getestet
hierdurch kann man auch höhere
geschwindigkeiten in der kurve erzielen
und die kräfte berechnen wir befinden
uns hier auf unserer teststrecke auf die
teststrecke erproben wir unsere
feuerwehrfahrzeuge in der kombination
fahrgestell aufbau komplett mit wasser
und der ausrüstung beladen im
bremsverhalten beschleunigungsverhalten
im schleuderball die 1927 gebaute
drehleiter kl 27 hatte lediglich 70 ps
unter der haube und schleppte sich mit
rund 45 km h zum einsatzort
heute werden die fahrzeuge je nach größe
und ausstattung mit bis zu 400 ps
betrieben und können mehr als das
doppelte an geschwindigkeit erreichen
eine zügige aber auch sichere anfahrt
zum einsatzort ist daher auch garant für
eine effektive bekämpfung und rettung im
notfall
wie bei den klassischen automobilen auch
werden die fahrzeuge mit
unterschiedlichen szenarien wie zb
aquaplaning und verschiedenen
bodenbelägen konfrontiert die
königsklasse ist gewiss das
überdimensionale und durchaus imposante
löschfahrzeug für die flughäfen mit
ihrer beeindruckenden lösch kraft der
dragon spreche zwar kein feuer sondern
kraft und wirkungsvoll wasser aus
mehreren pumpen
angetrieben von erstaunlichen 1200 ps
erreicht der dragon bereits in 25
sekunden über 80 km h
wenn es der einsatz erfordert
beschleunigt der gigant auf bis zu 135
km h und das obwohl sich bis zur 17
tausend liter wasser in seinem bauch
befinden
zusätzlich kann das fahrzeug noch 1500
liter schaum auf den brandherd werfen
gerade bei einem flugzeugunglück
unverzichtbar
bemerkenswert ist dass der dragon sogar
während der fahrt löschen kann
der dragon wird in unterschiedlichen
größen gebaut als sechs achse oder in
der großen variante mit acht achsen
selbstverständlich sind beide fahrzeuge
allrad betrieben eine gelungene
kombination aus kraft schnelligkeit und
intelligenz der erste drachen der wasser
spuckt und feuer bekämpft
von dieser technik konnten die
feuerwehrmänner anfang und mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts nur träumen
ihre einsätze waren oft mit einem
himmelfahrtskommando vergleichbar die
verluste waren entsprechend groß schon
damals galt die devise möglichst nahe an
den brandherd heranzukommen um das feuer
unter kontrolle zu bringen doch durch
die unzureichende ausrüstung und
bekleidung waren die männer häufig
selbst in gefahr opfer der flammen zu
werden heutzutage ist die feuerwehr
spätestens in 10 minuten am einsatzort
und dank der elektronischen
unterstützung heißt es schon nach
wenigen minuten wasser marsch früher war
man in erster linie auf mechanik und
muskelkraft angewiesen daher verzögerte
sich der löscheinsatz eines jedoch
vereint die feuerwehrleute damals wie
heute mut disziplin kameradschaft und
charakter stärke
das feuerwehrwesen wurde in der
anfangszeit in den mitte des 19
jahrhunderts sehr stark von
militärischen disziplin abgeleitet und
von militärischen organisationen es war
dann oft so dass kommen dann auch all
die offiziere waren die militärzeit was
gelernt haben und die disziplinen die
feuerwehr gebracht haben im übrigen gibt
es bei der feuerwehr eine klassische
kommandostruktur und deshalb wird bei
der feuerwehr auch und historisch
sowieso sehr viel exerziert und auch
durch organisiert und durch kommentiert
und ein befehl ein einsatzbefehl deshalb
durchaus mit militärischen
grundstrukturen zusammen
nur durch die klaren regeln und
kommandos bekommt man die oft
chaotischen zustände am unfallort auch
in den griff
hier an der baden-württembergischen
feuerwehrschule werden alle szenarien
trainiert so projektleiter andreas meyer
hier finden sich keine helden oder
einzeln von feuerwehr funktioniert nur
im ziel man sieht nichts man man hört
nur prasseln man muss sich mit den
händen orientieren und in solche
situationen gehe ich nicht mit dem herrn
müller-lüdenscheid sondern ich gehe mit
dem franz ich gehe mit dem mit martina
darein die ich kenne die furcht weiß
genau weiß wie die leute ticken und wie
die auch wissen wie ich ticke hier hat
sich seit gründer konrad dittrich
magirus nichts geändert es sind die
stillen helden die sich freiwillig der
gefahr stellen um andere zu retten dabei
gehen sie oft bis ans limit auch die
feuerwehrschule in bruchsal ist bei
weitem kein abenteuerspielplatz für
große jungs ganz im gegenteil
wir arbeiten hier mit rauch simulation
und auch mit einer flamme natürlich eine
gas befeuerung und wir kriegen natürlich
auch hier im deckenbereich temperaturen
bis 450 grad
dementsprechend sind die übungen sehr
realistisch und wir achten natürlich auf
unsere lehrgangsteilnehmer
dass hier die verletzungsgefahr so
gering wie möglich gehalten wird die
hohen körperlichen anforderungen und das
gefahrenpotenzial waren gewiss die
wichtigsten argumente warum die einsätze
bis vor einigen jahren fast
ausschließlich von männern durchgeführt
wurden im zwanzigsten jahrhundert wäre
eine frau am brandherd undenkbar gewesen
das hat sich inzwischen geändert
teamgeist soziale kompetenz und
zuverlässigkeit sind oft wichtiger als
muskelkraft aber es gibt noch mehr
gründe gerade als frau in der feuerwehr
den traumjob zu finden
einfach jeden tag neue herausforderungen
die anforderungen an die feuerwehr sind
gewachsen
binnen sekunden müssen die retter die
situation analysieren handeln und dabei
das eigene und das leben der kameraden
schützen
[Musik]
es ist sicherlich so dass die
einsatzleiter an der einsatzstelle auf
jeden fall immer den eigenschutz
voranstellen also es macht keinen sinn
ein unnötiges risiko einzugehen für eine
vielleicht vermeintlich noch befindliche
person in einem gebäude wenn ich aber
weiß ich schicke dort zwei gesunde
feuerwehr menschen in diesen
innenangriff reihen also damit möchte
sich niemand belassen die feuerwehr ist
im übrigen die letzte institution in
deutschland die über zwei jahrhunderte
höchstes ansehen und größte beliebtheit
in der bevölkerung genießt die
gesellschaft hat sich verändert das bild
der feuerwehr ist geblieben ihre
tugenden sind ein vorbild für alle
menschen ihr mut und ihre freiwillige
einsatzbereitschaft vermitteln stolz und
anerkennung und verdiene höchsten
respekt
[Musik]
jeden tag und jede nacht auf dem lande
und in der stadt berufs wehren und
einheiten der freiwilligen feuerwehr
männer die einen der gefährlichsten
berufe der welt haben
zehntausende von feuerwehrleuten gibt es
und hunderttausende die hinter ihnen
steht die ihnen helfen ihnen das
rüstzeug für den kampf gegen den roten
hahn schaffen moderne fahrzeuge modernes
gerät
präzisionsarbeit verrichtet in dem
bewusstsein dass jeder fehler jede
nachlässigkeit
menschenleben kosten kann
[Musik]
unter den helfern der männer mit dem
leder schutz im nacken steht in
vorderster linie magirus nicht erst seit
gestern seit mehr als 100 jahren
inzwischen seit mehr als 150 jahren
konrad dittrich magirus hat die
feuerwehr nicht nur technisch sondern
auch menschlich geprägt
er hat die ersten leitlinien für seine
turner und feuerwehrleute erstellt die
bis heute noch bestand haben
es sind die männer auf den leitern
hinter den sprit pumpen und unter den
gasmasken es ist dieser ganz besonderen
menschenschlag der in der lage ist diese
leistung im team abzurufen
die einsätze schweißen zusammen bilden
ein blindes und unverrückbares vertrauen
gemeinsam verdrängt man die gefahr
selbst zum opfer zu werden
vor 150 jahren waren es in erster linie
häuser brände heute kämpft man in u
bahnen an flughäfen und bei gift
transporten gewiss hat sich die technik
enorm entwickelt dennoch laut immer
wieder die gefahr
natürlich ist sich jeder seiner gefahr
bewusst jeder geht auch mal ein gewisses
risiko ein
aber auch hier muss eine führungskraft
darauf achten dass hier nicht über die
stränge geschlagen hat einerseits ist
das die aufgabe aus der viele
feuerwehrmänner ihre motivation schöpfen
andererseits muss diese aber auch
bewältigt werden sie kommen binnen
sekunden von null auf hundert werden mit
chaos leid tragik toten verletzten und
tränen konfrontiert diese einsätze
müssen auch verarbeitet und besprochen
werden um seelisch nicht gänzlich
abzustumpfen
ihre sensibilität ist wichtig um im
ernstfall auch intuitiv richtig zu
handeln
insofern gehen alle nach dem einsatz ein
typisches ritual
[Musik]
also was sie jetzt mitbekommen dass er
sieht so aus als wäre es nur einfach das
aufräumen und wieder in das fahrzeug in
einsatzbereitschaft zu stellen aber es
ist mehr es ist zum einen dass jeder für
sich mal ein bisschen den film rückwärts
laufen lässt was für eindrücke habe ich
da jetzt mitgenommen und dann natürlich
auch dieses zusammenstehen zusammen
miteinander reden um mitzubekommen das
was mich bewegt bewegt nicht nur nicht
sondern auch einen anderen von meinen
leuten häufig kennen sich die
feuerwehrleute seit jahren aus ihrem
verband oder dem gemeinsamen einsatz im
löschzug
dieses vertrauen ist eine große stütze
bei der verarbeitung
dies ist heute nicht anders als zu
beginn des feuerwehrwesens es waren
freunde bekannte kollegen und
vereinskameraden die hier gemeinsam am
strang zogen und sich den flammen zur
wehr setzten
seit jahrzehnten werden die metropolen
in erster linie von berufsfeuerwehren
geschützt wodurch die strukturen
anonymer wurden
die ländlichen regionen werden jedoch
bis heute zu fast 100 prozent von den
freiwilligen feuerwehren geschützt im
dritten reich wurde die feuerwehr der
polizei unterstellt und zur
schutzpolizei umbenannt eine ungewohnte
situation für die stillen helden aus
diesen zwängen konnte sie sich nach dem
krieg befreit feuerwehrleute wollen
stets unabhängig bleiben und keinerlei
macht position einnehme
bis heute hat sich daran nichts geändert
ein grund warum die feuerwehr über den
zeitraum ihrer geschichte stets einen
positiven eindruck in der gesellschaft
hinterlassen hat dieses phänomen hat
übrigens nicht nur für deutschland
bestand sondern gilt weltweit in rio de
janeiro ebenso wie natürlich ganz
besonders in new york
also es ist so die feuerwehren haben
sich sehr gut entwickelt von
süddeutschland aus im ganzen
deutschsprachigen raum prächtig
entwickelt berlin hat sogar 1850 schon
eine berufsfeuerwehr gegründet und
aufgestellt weil sie nehmen das nicht
mit freiwilligen bewerkstelligt haben
und so haben sich die feuerwehren
wirklich prächtig entwickelt bis in die
heutige zeit heute gibt es 100
berufsfeuerwehren im bundesgebiet sowie
über 22.000 freiwillige feuerwehren
insgesamt sind über eine million
bundesbürger in einer feuerwehr aktiv
eine erstaunliche zahl inzwischen auf
rund 70.000 frauen
[Musik]
bereits bei der fahrt zum unfallort
werden taktische maßnahmen
durchgesprochen dabei sind die
einsatzkräfte beileibe nicht nur
feuerwehrmänner es sind absolute
spezialisten auf ihrem gebiet
sie müssen chemische zusammenhänge
ebenso schnell und klar analysieren wie
physikalische sie bringen medizinisches
wissen ebenso an den unfallort wie
absolute fitness ausdauer und
nervenstärke sie sind maschinisten
rettungssanitäter schlosser elektriker
mechaniker zimmermänner techniker
mechatroniker und auch manchmal
seelsorger kurz sie sind die deutsche
feuerwehr
[Musik]